this sunday is the summer solstice the
longest day of the year
the alzheimer's association chooses this
day
to raise awareness for people living
with alzheimer's disease
and their caregivers who care for them
because every day can feel like the
longest day when you're dealing
with the challenges of dementia well you
can help while entertaining
dad out at the las vegas aviators game
aviators game on this sunday
five dollars from every ticket goes to
the alzheimer's association this sunday
and thanks to our outrageous las vegas
heat there's a fun
challenge that you can participate in
it's called you bet your ice
for a small donation you can wager how
long it will take
for a 20 pound block of ice sitting in
the hot sun near the third base side of
the las vegas ballpark
to melt kat hartley and nancy nelson
joined me this morning from the
alzheimer's association
to tell us more about it we still want
to try to find joy
right and some fun no matter what we
might be going
through um and i think it's just a fun
way
to show really a day is really long
right and especially in caregiving um
and we're going to do it on the day with
the most sun but that's what we are
bringing in the association
light to a really kind of dark subject
um and this way we can just have a
little fun
while we're watching blocks of ice
smelled in the desert
and you know it's all so special special
to us because both of our fathers had
alzheimer's
so um and and to do it on father's day
that's a a tribute to both of our
fathers
kat tell me about the fundraising
efforts through the alzheimer's
association
on the longest day so that has really
become
a a rallying day for the alzheimer's
association hasn't
it yes and what's unique about the
longest day
event is that individuals across the
country get to pick
things they enjoy doing it can be baking
it can be
hiking yoga all day going to a movie all
day
so it's a chance to be creative in your
own way
and just to bring awareness to your
friends family and community
more about the disease and you know
raise some funds
obviously to help support them well if
you'd like to join in the challenge you
can place a wager for when that block of
ice will melt
on cats the facebook page link there
with the link to the alzheimer's
association webpage we've got
those on our website eightnewsnow.com
she's on her way to raising that money
a lot of folks think they know exactly
when that ice is gonna melt
alex it's a fun challenge yes that is so
cool
i can't wait for that all right thank